if I say the phrase tax season to you
you likely imagine a period in Spring
leading up to the middle of April this
is after all when Tax Day falls on or
around April the 15th however what if I
were to tell you that tax season was
every season what if I were to let slip
that every day even today is tax day how
would that make you feel unsettled
alarmed well not it off those taxes paid
for our roads our hospitals and other
essential Services they also paid for my
high school and I turned out just fine
thank you very much the point is we pay
taxes all year long sales tax gas tax
and even income tax picture in your mind
a business no never mind this is a video
format we'll do it together imagine
sleepy time Products Incorporated a
fictitious business to be clear it does
not exist but if it did sleepy time
would would make mattresses pillows hair
Bonnets and eye masks a cozy place a
comfy place I would like to introduce
you to two workers at sleepy time
products each of whom will showcase a
different way of paying taxes Kesha is a
product engineer she researches new
mattress Technologies squish ability of
the mattress topper increases by
14% when we use the reticulated foam
fascinating kha is a full-time employee
over here in the sales department is
Carlos I'm so glad you feel that way
we're very proud of these
products what's that oh I sleep on the
G20
Alpha yeah with the cooling Wings
exactly Carlos is not a salaried
full-time employee he is a contractor
for sleepy time Kesha and Carlos make
the same amount of income but their tax
arrangements are very different when
Kesha start started at sleepy times she
was given an I9 form and a W4 form but
Carlos Carlos the contractor received
only a W9 Kesha's I9 and Carlos's W9
have the same function they tell your
employer that you're eligible to work in
the US so they can tell the IRS how much
they paid you the only difference is
that the I9 is for employees and the W9
is for contractors picture a world in
which taxes are subtracted from the
paycheck of the American work worker
before that paycheck even hits their
bank account picture a world in which
you spend all year paying income taxes a
little at a time so that by Year's End
you owe nothing at all submitted for
your approval Internal Revenue Service
form W4 the W4 form that Kesha received
helps her figure out how much of her
paycheck should be withheld for income
taxes how much of each paycheck should
she send right to the US Treasury to do
her share of paying for roads and
bridges and schools and drinking water
the the more she withholds now the less
she'll have to pay later but if she
overpays and withholds more than she
owes in taxes she'll get more back later
as a refund okay I've got a partner in
kid at home I'm not going to withhold as
much income for taxes because of the
deductions I get for being married and
having a child more take-home pay it is
do you see for Keesha tax day occurs
Every payday as a contractor Carlos
doesn't get the same perks or benefits
as Kesha does as a full-time employee
like employer provided health care or
contributions to a retirement account he
has to do his own tax withholding
because sleepy time products accounting
department isn't doing it for him the
way they are for Kesha lucky me Carlos
has to do his own withholding combining
his various sources of income to pay
estimated quarterly taxes every 3 months
he sends checks to the tax authorities
in his State and to the federal
government paying a percentage based on
the amount of money he expects to make
that year figuring that out was
relatively easy the IRS has a worksheet
1040 es now even though Carlos pays his
taxes once a quarter and Kesha's come
out of her paycheck automatically every
2 weeks when January comes around sleepy
time product sends out forms that detail
how much money Carlos and Kesha made in
the previous tax year hello what's this
Carlos's 1099 MK shows him how much
sleepy time products paid him this tax
year with no deductions ah got it
whereas Kesha's W2 shows her not only
how much sleepy time products paid her
but also how much of her income was
withheld as taxes woo they had better
name a train station after me or
something Kesha and her partner rent
their home whereas Carlos is a homeowner
so Carlos gets another tax form from his
mortgage lender form $198 showing how
much he paid an interest on his mortgage
this year woo they better name a bank
branch after me or something Carlos is
in luck however the interest on his
mortgage payment is deductible the 1098
lets him subtract that number from his
overall taxable income thus lowering his
tax burden as the filing deadline of
April 15th approaches Kesha and Carlos
make preparations Kesha runs the numbers
she's paid enough with her withholding
throughout the year that she'll actually
get a refund from the federal government
huh I guess I overpaid looks like the
orthodon is finally getting that last
payment Kesha has effectively been
paying taxes all year long because
because of her elections on her W4 form
money is subtracted from each paycheck
and sent to the US Treasury by the time
April rolls around she's all settled up
however Carlos had no withholding as a
contractor and he had a few more side
gigs than he predicted that weren't
covered by his estimated quarterly
payments therefore he owes money at the
end of the year hm so let's subtract my
mortgage interest from my taxable income
hey all right that's not as bad as I
thought no indeed Carlos with a little
planning and forethought there's no need
to fear the tax man stride confidently
into tomorrow in the knowledge that
tomorrow is tax day and so is the day
after that and the day after that and
the day after that but don't worry it's
all going to be
okay